مهما كان حجمها الامر يتعلق
بمعالجه يتغير المناخيه
بمساله انتشال الناس من
الفقر
والتخلص من كافه الاوبئه واعطاء مواطنين
كافه الفرس الامر يتعلق بتامين الامن
والازدهار لاطفالنا وتامين الديناميه التي
التي
تتحلى بها الديمقراطيه اننا
ملتزمون بقيمنا ورؤيتنا في العالم ان
شركتنا مع الهند سوف تستمر الى فتره طويله
والى ما ابعد من القرن الحادي والعشرين
وفيما يخص التعاون التكنولوجي فان شركتنا
ايضا عميقه ونتطلع للعمل معكم
[موسيقى]
انني
سوف اعمل على دعم هذه الجهود المشتركه
بيننا اشكركم على وجودكم هنا
والان احيل الكلمه الى سعاده رئيس الوزراء
الرئيس بايدن
واصدقائي
احيانا من الصعب ان
نتحدث امام الصحافه لكن اولا وقبل كل شيء
اود ان اشكر الرئيس بايدن على المشاركه في
هذا الحدث
ولعلكم رايتم انه
ان كافه القطاعات ممثله هنا وعلى راسها
التكنولوجيا وهي التي باتت تلامس حياتنا
بصوره يوميه
وهناك شركات
ذات سمعه
معروفه
ويمكننا ان نعمل معا من اجل رسمي ملامح
العالم لكن تحت قياده الرئيس بايدن
التكنولوجيا
وفهم اهميتها
افضى الى تحقيق التقدم الذي نعمت به
الولايات المتحده وجيل الشباب في الهند
وبفضله
المهارات
التي يتمتعون بها
فانني ارى ان
جيل الشباب وهذه المهارات قد يكونون هم
الضمان
وفي هذا الصباح تحدثت مع مجموعه من
الاصدقاء
وهذا قد يمنحنا
الضمانات للمستقبل
هذه مجموعه
صغيره من الاشخاص لكنها مجموعه واعده
للغايه
وسوف تقوم بتوجيه بوصله العالم لانها سوف
تعمل على بناء مستقبل العالم
ومن خلال عزيمه
من خلال عزيمتنا والعمل على رسمي رؤيه
للمستقبل وطموحات الهند وقوه رئيس بايدن
فهناك امكانيه ان
ان نعمل على تامين هذه الفرصه
للعالم باسره
سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذه الكلمه للرئيس
الوزراء الهندي نارين مودي مع الرئيس
الامريكي بعد مفاوضات بين
الرجلين حول توطيد العلاقات والتعاون في
كافه المجالات وتحسين وتعميق العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات